tens of thousands more people are
fleeing deadly gang violence in El
Salvador
while some communities search for ways
to defend themselves one mayor created a
network of informants to help push
criminals out of his town Mayo mayor
Mauricio Villanova enlisted local people
who were fed up with the violence Omar
Villafranca is in San Jose guayaba where
citizens follow a no-tolerance gang
policy at night san jose y avala streets
are filled with little boys and girls
shops now stay open late into the night
owners don't have to worry about being
extorted credit goes to mayor Mauricio
Villanova who with the help of police
pushed gang members off the streets and
out of town
Villanova earned the trust of the
townspeople by promising them if they
hear or see gang activity they'll get
police to help if the police are too
slow he patrols the town with the pistol
by his side the town rules are posted
high on a billboard and everyone has to
follow zero tolerance gang a policy you
need three things he says to control the
territory the trust of the people and to
communicate with residents the mayor
also credits some American aid dollars
that help rebuild the town square that
attracts families and so far keeps gangs
out Omar Villafranca CBS News San Jose
why allow El Salvador all right Omar
thank you